the big story of course right now is the
passing of queen elizabeth and it's
it's taken the whole focus of the world
because people feel as though
a great age is gone now you know our our
last connection to this great age when
western civilization seemed to flourish
more seem to make more sense
is finally gone and we knew it was going
to come the woman was 96 years old but
it doesn't make it any less sad
there have been some really off-key
responses i've noticed this
uh especially from people on the left
who
while they well they may actually have
liked the woman and while they may be
trying to be polite on her passing
they they don't like monarchy they don't
like tradition they don't like western
civilization so they don't really like
anything that the woman stood for
and and so it's created a real
challenge in the way that they respond
to this yesterday before the news came
that the queen had died the white house
was asked about
her ailing the fact that all of her
family members were traveling to her the
fact that it seemed like
time was short
the response from karine jean-pierre
i think tells you everything you need to
know about how the left is
how the left stands at this moment in
history
on queen elizabeth she's served for
nearly a third of american history so
how does president biden
view the special relationship between
the u.s and the uk if there were to be a
transition in the british monarchy
so don't wanna you know we feel like
it's inappropriate to talk about uh
hypotheticals here um
we but we what i will say about the
relationship uh with the
with the united kingdom as the president
said in celebration of queen's platinum
jubilee which is not too long ago under
and this is quote under her reign the
relationship between the united kingdom
and the united states has grown stronger
and closer than ever the president as
you all know has known the queen for
over three decades he's met he's met her
personally three times once was in june
of 2021
over the years including as i said twice
last year again
we see
this relationship
is stronger grows stronger every
close stronger and closer
and
again our hearts the presence
has he said uh our thoughts and our
hearts are with the queen her family uh
and also the people of the united
kingdom
okay perfectly nice thing to say i'm not
criticizing the sentiment at all
i am criticizing the language did you
hear what she said she said and and she
apparently was quoting the president
here
our thoughts and our hearts are with the
queen
that's a strange phrase you don't hear
that for our our thoughts and hearts are
with you
that phrase is a substitute for our
thoughts and prayers are with you but
the white house can't bring itself to
say prayers the left has made a point in
recent years of mocking the phrase
thoughts and prayers and they mock
thoughts and prayers because they
believe that prayers are not efficacious
because they don't believe in god
and and the white house as the
chief representative of the american
left
can't bring itself to to use that phrase
either
i promise you that was intentional the
omission of the word prayers and maybe
maybe some of them do believe in prayers
but they feel like the base is so
atheistic that they can't use the phrase
or maybe as i suspect
the administration is just not
not particularly christian not
particularly
uh religious kind of mocks all of those
things
i unfortunately i think it's the latter
really sad because queen elizabeth
in from the earliest days of her reign
was a defender of religion
and public religion private religion too
and private faith and she
viewed herself as serving god and i i
think she did
serve god and she said look people are
in this modern world they're trying to
toss out all the ageless truths and the
ageless ideals
namely religion the first on the list
was religion and she said we really
shouldn't do that when we when we lose
that we're really lost
and
when i heard that statement from the
white house it it deepened my sense of
dread that we were going to lose the
queen
because i thought man you guys
you guys just don't get it no one seems
to get it or maybe they do get it and
they're
they're happy not that the woman has
passed but that that age has passed and
that sense of tradition and dignity and
and the notion that one serves one's
family and community and country and
ultimately one serves one's god
so many people at funerals think
after they finish thinking about the
person who has died they turn their
thoughts onto themselves and sometimes
people cry at funerals because they're
thinking of their own mortality and it's
a natural reaction i think a lot of
people are thinking that way with the
passing of queen elizabeth we're
thinking about ourselves what does this
mean for the world that we're living in
i had this thought last year i went to
my friend's wedding in france
and took sweet little alisa and
the babies and we made a whole family
trip out of it and we're walking around
paris and sweet little elisa out of
nowhere she's looking at the building
she goes
man
that's obviously elise's voice man meg
why can't we have these beautiful things
how come
how come the french get beautiful things
why don't we get beautiful things
so that's a great question
because there are there are beautiful
buildings in america there's obviously a
lot of beautiful geography but there's
some beautiful art some beautiful
buildings
but not a lot they're kind of few and
far between and most of the buildings
that have been built in the last century
have just been these kind of glass and
steel monstrosities or this brutalist
hideous sort of architecture
you walk around
a city that's from another age
older cities and you think this is so
beautiful
why can't we have that
and that that is the point of the
monarchy that is the point of the royal
family and the the last really prominent
one is in the united kingdom is to give
the nation
something to look up to
and it's a service role i mean they you
know these are uh
these are people whose job it is to
serve the country they happen to wear
tiaras but their job is to go out and
open up grocery stores and help
encourage the country
but it's to give them a sense of dignity
not just efficiency not just
you know ticking up the gdp a little
further but a sense of dignity a sense
of tradition a sense of culture a sense
of art
and and the question that we have is why
can't we have that
here
we have a different political tradition
i think i think we could keep cast our
eyes up a little bit but we've we've
really got to dig in deep and not just
cast away all of the past you know
when
when the queen died there were
rainbows that appeared over buckingham
palace and and over windsor castle when
the queen died there was a double
rainbow over buckingham palace and then
when they lowered the flag to half-mast
very briefly a giant rainbow appeared
over windsor castle and it's it's not
lost on me either that the queen died on
mary miss on the feast of the nativity
of mary queen of heaven and earth
i don't think that's just a coincidence
you know i i believe in providence i
think that's you know providence is when
god kind of peeks out from behind the
curtain and winks at you
and it is it is a great consolation
because it's a reminder that no matter
how how useless our good works seem to
be no matter how pointless it seems to
be to live a good life in a culture that
doesn't really seem to reward that all
that much
there is an order to things there is an
overarching providence and we can see it
peak out every now and again and it's a
great encouragement i'm so glad you
liked that clip now if you want to get
even more clips
would you please ring that bell
subscribe get the notifications we'll
see you next time
[Music]